YouTube is branching out as a streaming
service you can rent or purchase films
directly through the site for a small
fee but now they're setting themselves
apart from the pack by releasing almost
100 films for free well free with ADD
breaks at least here are some of the
best free movies YouTube has to offer
2014's very good girls certainly has all
the marks of a prestige indie film it's
cast includes Demi Moore Ellen Barkin
Richard Dreyfuss and Peter Sarsgaard
alongside stars Dakota Fanning and
Elizabeth Olsen you may recognize her as
the younger sibling of the Olsen twins
who has since made a name for herself as
Scarlet Witch in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the film tells the story of two
young women Lily and Jerry who fall for
the same boy David played by Boyd
Holbrook during their last summer before
College both girls have to whether
personal stripe that goes beyond typical
teenage girl drama complicated by the
fact that David is more interested in
Lily creating a rift between the two
friends the film wasn't exactly a hit
with critics but it was praised for its
sharp writing and excellent performances
if you haven't heard of it it's worth a
watch and anyone who struggled through
their teenage years will absolutely find
a moment or two that are incredibly
sometimes painfully relatable this 2011
documentary by director David Gelb
focuses on Jiro Ono an 85 year old
master chef and the proprietor of Sookie
owashi Jiro an extremely unique
michelin-starred sushi restaurant in
Tokyo the legendary restaurant only
offers a 20 course fixed menu of dishes
that costs at least thirty thousand
Japanese yen or just under three hundred
US dollars the restaurant also only has
ten seats and is located oddly enough
inside of a subway station the movie
also shines a light on Ono's children
who each follow their father's footsteps
in their own ways Takashi zeros younger
son left the nest to open a restaurant
of his own elsewhere in Japan his older
brother Yoshikazu considers himself
duty-bound to take over soo kyobashi
Jiro one day and is shown still working
alongside their father originally Gelb
was going to make a documentary about
sushi culture in general but after
eating a Giro's restaurant he was struck
by the chef's artistry commitment and
focus not to mention his incredible
sushi he then decided to focus
exclusively on Jiro instead you don't
need to be a foodie to enjoy the movie
either
the film has been met with near
universal credit
a claim it was even parodied by Fred
Armisen on a series documentary now on
which Armisen learns how to make the
perfect rain of rice from his father uh
no nonsense chef some have described
jiro Dreams of Sushi as a perfect
antidote to today's haphazard and hectic
culture in that watching a master of his
craft perfect his techniques through
constant patient practice may inspire
viewers to stop chasing the next big
thing and learn to focus the late great
Stanley was more than just a comic book
writer he was a self-made superhero and
a legend unto himself after his passing
at the age of 95 in 2018 there's no
better time to watch with great power
the Stanley story which chronicles
everything from his childhood to the
creation of seminal characters like the
Hulk spider-man and the x-men Lee's life
was so long and storied that many have
forgotten how many things he lived
through and accomplished as a younger
man he served in World War two when he
returned home and got into the comics
industry in the 1950s he engaged in a
hard-fought battle to prevent comic
books from being censored the
documentary wisely lets Lee speak for
himself through most of its 80 minute
runtime telling stories about his humble
beginnings a particularly moving
antidote reveals that he once came close
to quitting comics altogether until his
wife Joan convinced him to write what he
really wanted to write about which
resulted in the creation of the
Fantastic Four no documentary on Stan
Lee would be complete without plenty of
Marvel stars and celebrities to talk
about his influence and a wealth of
famous faces appear from Tobey Maguire
and samuel l.jackson to Paris Hilton and
Ringo Starr the film serves as the
perfect ode to an icon and shows that he
was still at his core relatable and
accessible even as perhaps the most
influential man in comic book history
you know I guess one person
an ambitious yet seriously low-budget
science-fiction film from Ecuadorian
director sebastián cordero euro per
report features a few actors you might
recognize the movie stars and bet the
VIPs best known for Schindler's List and
Matilda as well as the late michael
nyqvist who appeared in Mission
Impossible Ghost Protocol John wick and
the Swedish millennium series the movie
focuses on a group of astronauts
searching for life on Europa one of
Jupiter's moons six months into the
mission the ship is suddenly hit by a
solar storm which leaves them unable to
communicate with anyone on earth they
then suffer a series of accidents before
eventually landing on Europa discovering
evidence that a single-celled organism
exists on the planet though they managed
to restore their communications the crew
never makes it back to earth leaving
behind only a video that gets
transmitted back home the making of the
film was extremely faithful to the
realities of space travel and of Europa
itself the filmmakers used maps for
accuracy and the used footage of
spacewalks from the International Space
Station and space shuttle to correctly
portray how a human might move within
space these tactics paid off when it
came to critical reception among other
positive reviews space comm noted that
the film was extraordinarily realistic
and it was nominated for a Bradbury
award by the science fiction and fantasy
writers of America in 2013 flawless
features an all-star pair as its two
main cast members Demi Moore and Michael
Caine both of whom shine in this
creative heist thriller the film opens
on Laura Quinn who is being interviewed
for a relatively superficial piece about
being the first woman to run the London
diamond corporation but things take a
turn when she suddenly places an
enormous diamond on the table in front
of her and announces that she stole it
in a flashback to 1960 the film tells
the story of Queens early days at the
London diamond corporation where she
keeps losing jobs to relatively
unqualified men making things worse she
finds out from the building's janitor
mr. hobbs that she's not only not going
to be promoted but that the higher-ups
are planning to fire her together they
put together a plan to rob the
corporation but as with every good heist
film several twists and turns keep Quinn
and Hobbes from easily accomplishing
their goals at every fork in the road
the two are tracked by mr. Finch a
private investigator hired to look into
their amateur heist while the film
earned lukewarm reviews from critics at
the time of its release it's still well
worth a watch featuring an engrossing
story with a number of sharp turns as
well as an excellent cast this
oscar-nominated documentary about the
excesses of one Christian summer camp
may seem at first that it's choosing
sides by purely existing but Rachel
Grady and Heidi Ewing the directors of
Jesus camp have assured viewers that
they truly had no agenda during the
making of their film according to the
filmmakers they always intended the
movie to simply be an accurate and
honest representation of camps that
aimed to radicalize Christian teenagers
indoctrinating them with a drive to take
back the country in the name of Jesus
Christ the film focuses on a camp based
in North Dakota called the kids of fire
school of ministry turning an even
narrower focus to three children who
attend Levi Rachel and Tory switching
between the camp itself and a prayer
conference in Missouri at christ's
triumphant Church the film casts the
camp's leader Becky Fisher in a dubious
light the movie includes ten scenes such
as an encounter between Fisher and
conservative talk radio host Mike
Papantonio who questions the camp's
leaders choice to push extreme messages
on young children the film immediately
stirred up controversy by showing scenes
where children were seemingly
indoctrinated against quote Muslim
extremists and told to become members of
a so-called army of God many critics
viewed the portrayal of evangelical
Christians as unflinching and sometimes
disturbing and Fisher eventually shut
down the camp a Miss criticism of her
teaching methods she also cited concerns
about vandalism in the aftermath of the
film when she closed the camp whenever a
documentary incites that kind of intense
reaction it's usually worth a watch
based on actual events the world's
fastest Indian tells the story of Burt
Munro a real-life speed racer from inva
Cargill New Zealand who famously rode in
Indian Scout motorcycle that he
outfitted to his own specifications
Munro as played by Anthony Hopkins set a
high number of land speed records for
motorcycles with engines under 1,000 CC
throughout the 1950s and 1960s as the
film tells us he encountered a number of
hardships on this path to speed and
glory after irritating his neighbors at
home in New Zealand he hops a cargo ship
to the States
while he's initially looked down upon by
the people of Los Angeles he eventually
succeeds thanks to a can-do attitude and
pure friendliness overcoming the odds he
arrives at the Bonneville Salt Flats the
real-life home of the Bonneville
Speedway and ends up breaking several
records before returning home to New
Zealand as
hero though some criticized the movie
for being historically inaccurate the
film received praise from both audiences
and critics infamous outlaw Butch
Cassidy and his accomplice the Sundance
Kid have been profiled almost countless
times of pop-culture one interpretation
of the story is the movie Blackthorne
starring lauded playwrights and actors
Sam Shepard as an agent Cassidy hiding
out in South America under the name
James Blackthorne shepard is joined by
Nikolaj coster-waldau as a young Cassidy
who you may recognize as Jaime Lannister
from Game of Thrones the film follows
butch returning to the United States
after the death of another Wild Bunch
accomplice at a price along the way he's
attacked by a mysterious Spaniard and
the two eventually team up for a robbery
leading to plenty of betrayals and
backstabbing along the way the film
received mixed reviews from critics
undoubtedly suffering from comparisons
to other depictions of Butch Cassidy in
film critics wrote that while some parts
of the film worked splendidly it fell
victim to certain Western cliches but
while the film as a whole has some flaws
Shepards performance was singled out for
praise in a wide array of reviews making
something special out of this character
study of a legendary outlaw a small
independent film that made a fairly big
impression great world of sound came out
during the heights of the reality TV
phenomenon in the late 2000s when it
seemed like anybody could become
instantly famous so long as they had a
little bit of skill and a whole lot of
luck directed by Craig Sobel this
unorthodox pseudo documentary features
Pat Healy as Martin and keen Holiday is
Clarence two men undercover on an actual
audition circuit who convinced strangers
to perform for them in exchange for free
recording sessions and Industry contacts
the people auditioning tricked into
thinking the two actors were record
industry executives were for the most
part entirely unaware that the project
was a film shoot exposing themselves
fully to the flow documentarians with a
fictional through line running alongside
real-life audition footage the movie
ultimately blurs fact and fiction ending
up being an incredibly revealing look at
the desire some have for fame and
celebrity
despite being hard to categorize great
world of sound was well received by
critics and his positive three star
review
Roger Ebert said the film was confident
and well designed defying genre to make
a memorable viewing experience